okay welcome to this video playing oops
the National masters village from Serbia
yeah I've got it right okay I'm trying
the Dutch very rarely play the Dutch him
I have played thus the Leningrad term
Dutch this line a couple of times in the
mid-2000s 2005-2006 I was looking for
uhm Jung sharp opening against d for
this was what I was coming up with my
results weren't too bad but it's a it's
a very tricky opening to play we can
easily have land into trouble okay this
is probably probably not too great this
very a quick assault on the King side
but um let's say let's see hmm yeah well
I don't really understand that at the
end I'm half we should reform isn't this
just good
OIC giving away the exchange I don't
think this is full compensation rookie
form and i don't i don't really believe
in ruby three staying in the spin maybe
maybe you can do that it looks it looks
ugly it's just a very annoying pin queen
d 31 maybe 23 here yeah maybe okay what
if I us move you want to play come on
just try to be quick iam oh he can just
take it I I mean even take only five I
really I really ignored this the sir not
too difficult possibility also attack or
am i doing him is not working at all wow
I can I completely miscounted I thought
okay just e5 check not quite sure when I
was thinking this is also a strange move
now I at least have root da next I'm not
sure what this accomplished 25 I think
it could have just taken e5 for nothing
and maybe I'm just seeing just not
judging this right as possible of course
ok worked yet I thought it was a bit
nonsensical to to a lower this year up
the aid you never know I mean it's it's
very active ok some rookie to those
those kind of moves at yes night takes
this is a real annoyance
it is bishop if having stood bishop
there's what do you want in the mix
hmm 30 a very tricky young knight I well
night before I have this would be too
okay well then let's just jump right
into it rookie tool sonai g4m taking be
to and if he takes on c6 I will grab f2
problem yeah it's up it's a complete
mess all very unintentional if I really
was just a blunder not sure what you
should do now let's out who just I'm
amazingly complicated
I I really am I really expect that white
should have some good move but i'm not
seeing one at the moment yeah this is
not the kind of move you dream of ok
just take here Oh is there something
better no that's probably okay yeah well
now now you need to check if there's a
direct win available
I take here Bishop f3 then take here I
cannot mate I can take here but there is
no maid i think i can i can take first
here i think this is a good idea anyway
and what now i don't i don't see ya
don't see a check made eyes got Queenie
five know as well chat became let's do
this first
check
what I actually forgot about is that he
simply has this check admit very easy
and I'm not threatening much the bishop
is very strong but I'm not really
threatening anything anything concrete
at the moment not even Queen f3 the look
is protecting that North already know
maybe queen aged three years a service a
bit of a threat it's still I'm very
tricky for white can easily blunder but
objectively speaking and probably worse
I mean much worse
check check I is gonna contract I didn't
see that at all the Queen e5 is
protecting time my name is protecting
the rook on a one check
and I have an H pawn this H porn is some
it's not bad at all cat or the Jeep own
check check no okay check I only had two
seconds flat whoreface on time yeah
that's the fair result anyway I'll
despite the fact that I had many chances
along the way I really had with e5 this
was really am too much yeah yeah this is
just a e5 is just a blondie well the cop
says its flavor but anyway as I should
just play something like that and they
have huge play along the f file he just
mistimed the open to position check this
95 just went straight away I don't know
what he was thinking it just winds
immediately no no cat defends at all
okay well this is just entirely entirely
unclear yeah i can i can draw with luke
f to check and this check check check
check no it's a perpetual well this is
this is also also possible but it's not
it's not convincing simply a i had
really forgotten about the check that
he's got this check only thought okay
queen move and then i play on the light
squares but just tempe wise it's not
checked snot on check check auntie I'm
losing
cando um I'm not entirely sure about
about this end game because of the
h-bomb however this is probably nonsense
I thought about this breakthrough g4 h4
and then push the g pramod it's it's not
on I only have 12 seconds this is the
main you sure played much quicker here
but I lost a couple of seconds each move
alright thanks for watching